WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
SINCE 9/11 THE U.S. HAS SPENT
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN LIVES
TRYING TO REMAKE THE MIDDLE
EAST IN OUR IMAGE.
IT IS SAD TO SAY IT OUT LOUD
BUT WE HAVE TO.
IT HASN'T WORKED.
MANY OF US THOUGHT IT WOULD
BUT IT HASN'T.
BY EVERY MEASURE OUR FOREIGN
WARS ENDED IN DISMAL FAILURE
FOR THE UNITED STATES.
HOWEVER NOBLE THEIR
INTENTIONS.
SOME DID HAVE NOBLE
DONALD TRUMP WAS ONE OF THE
RARE POLITICIANS HONEST ENOUGH
TO ADMIT THIS.
HE SAID IT OUT LOUD THREE
YEARS A AND PROMISED NOT TO
REPEAT THE SAME MISTAKES IF
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
PARTLY BECAUSE HE SAID THAT,
HE WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT.
NOW SOMETHING FASCINATING IS
HAPPENING.
THE VERY PEOPLE, IN SOME CASES
LITERALLY THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
LURED US IN TO THE IRAQ
QUAGMIRE 16 YEARS AGO ARE
DEMANDING A NEW WAR.
THIS ONE WITH IRAN.
THE PRESIDENT TO HIS GREAT
CREDIT APPEARS TO BE SKEPTICAL
OF THIS.
VERY SKEPTICAL.
IRAN RECENTLY DOWNED AN
UNMANNED AMERICAN DRONE.
THE PRESIDENT SPEAKING TODAY
SEEMED TO SUGGEST THIS
SHOULDN'T NECESSARILY TRIGGER
A CONFLICT WITH IRAN.
WATCH.
>> President Trump: IRAN
MADE A BIG MISTAKE.
THIS DRONE WAS IN
INTERNATIONAL WATERS CLEARLY.
WE HAVE IT DOCUMENTED.
I WOULD IMAGINE IT WAS A
GENERAL OR SOMEBODY WHO MADE A
MISTAKE SHOOTING THAT DRONE
DOWN.
FORTUNATELY THAT DRONE WAS
UNARMED.
THERE WAS NO MAN IN IT, THERE
WAS NO -- IT WAS JUST, IT WAS
OVER INTERNATIONAL WATERS.
CLEARLY OVER INTERNATIONAL
WATERS.
BE YOU WE DIDN'T HAVE A MAN OR
WOMAN IN THE DRONE.
NOBODY WAS IN THE DRONE.
I WOULD HAVE MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
LET ME TELL YOU.
I WOULD HAVE MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE IT
WAS INTENTIONAL IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW THE TRUTH.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN SOMEBODY
WHO WAS LOOSE AND STUPID THAT
DID IT.
>> Tucker: SO THAT IS NOT
NEARLY BELLICOSE ENOUGH FOR
THE CURRENT FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISH.
IN WASHINGTON MANY OF WHOM
CRAVE WAR WITH IRAN.
SENATOR GRAHAM SAYS AMERICANS
SHOULD BE READY FIGHT AND DIE
FOR SHIPPING LANES ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE WORLD.
WATCH.
>> HERE IS WHAT TO WATCH FOR.
IF THE IRANIANS FOLLOW THROUGH
ON THEIR THREAT TO START
ENRICHING AGAIN AT HIGHER
LEVELS TO BASICALLY TAKE THEIR
ENRICH.
PROGRAM A NUCLEAR LEVEL IN
TERMS OF THE WEAPON-GRADE
PRODUCTION, ISRAEL IS IN A
WORLD OF HURT.
SO THE BEST THING THE
PRESIDENT CAN DO IS STOP THAT.
HOW DO YOU STOP THAT?
TO MAKE IRAN UNDERSTAND YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO LET IT
HAPPEN, PUT THE OIL REFINERIES
ON A TARGET LIST, LOOK TO SINK
THE IRANIAN NAVY IF THEY
ATTACK SHIPPING AGAIN.
>> Tucker: UH-HUH.
SO IN WASHINGTON THERE ARE NO
REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR BEING
WRONG.
AS A RESULT, POLICY-MAKERS
ARE.
THEY MAKE THE SAME MISTAKES
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT JUST
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
AT THE "NEW YORK TIMES" LEFT
WING WAR MONGER BRET STEPHENS
CALLING TO SINK THE IRANIAN
NAVY.
JOHN BOLTON CHEERS HIM ON IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
BILL CRYSTAL NODS WITH
APPROVAL OUTSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE.
NONE OF THE PEOPLE WOULD ADMIT
THE ACTUAL INTENTION.
THEY DON'T REALLY WANT A WAR
WITH IRAN.
THAT IS A CROCK.
THEY WANT A WAR BADLY.
BADLY ENOUGH TO LIE ABOUT IT.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE PUTTING
AMERICAN TROOPS IN SITUATIONS
WHERE CONFLICT IS INEVITABLE,
TO START A WAR.